once upon a time there was no way of
getting to the homes east of the Las
Vegas wash here but then the bridge
which you see all these cars currently
on right now was built but with
surrounding Construction in the area and
what neighbors call a lack of traffic
control it's causing more daily dangers
a bridge meant for safety and
convenience seemingly doing the opposite
here I spent 45 minutes to an hour just
sitting in that line going down di
trying to make a left turn Carrie Levitt
is one of several living near this
bridge who say collisions near it have
grown common there's probably one or two
every other day and sometimes multiple
in the same day the 20 million dollar
Bridge started construction last year to
provide direct access over the Las Vegas
wash on Desert Inn now completed this
stretch of road has no stop signs no
stop lights for over a mile people can't
get out of the communities and then
people are are infuriated because they
have to wait in a mile long traffic to
get out pair that with construction on
Vegas Valley just a street over traffic
there is pushed here and the lack of
traffic control yielding extra cars
extra emotions and extra accidents and
then of course the stupid stuff happens
somebody doesn't want to wait goes
around the other cars side swipes
accidents
so what can be done leave it says more
traffic control but his and other
people's request for it have not
followed through basically we'll get
around to it when we get around to it
and basically you guys have to live with
it I don't have to live there it just a
catastrophe that they could have been
better planning
yeah Las Vegas Metro Police does confirm
there have been three critical incidents
happening at this intersection here all
within 2022 but they do add those
numbers they do not include the
non-critical non-critical instance
rather that these neighbors are
detailing reporting live from Desert Inn
and Hollywood Ryan Matthey 8 News Now